une arrivée triomphante acclamé par ses
partisans venus nombreux au meeting
baptisé de la victoire donald trump n'en
démord pas il va à nouveau conquérir la
maison blanche
je crois qu'on est puissions gagner la
floride
et si on gagne nos aïeux historiquement
on n'a jamais perdu l'élection c'est
sans aucun doute une première mais la
vérité c'est qu'on avait raison
elle n'a pas perdu l'élection on est en
train de gagner cette élection
son adversaire démocrate a pourtant
remporté les voix de 306 grands
électeurs selon les résultats officiels
contre seulement 270 pour donald trump
ses partisans eux crient à la fraude ne
sera jamais notre président jammeh non
il pourrait aussi bien retourner dans
son sous sol c'est fini pour lui
nous n'allons pas nous contenter d'une
défaite maintenant il ya trop de
tricherie nous accepterions une élection
juste mais ce n'était pas une élection
juste c'est un peu importe à quel point
le système est ou a été truqué vous
savez la seule façon pour nous de nous
faire entendre c'est d'être présent à ce
moment là des républicains qui vont donc
voter le 5 janvier prochain en géorgie
pour un autre scrutin
tout aussi crucial celui des deux
sénateurs de l'état qui pourrait bien
peser sur la présidence de joe biden si
ces deux sièges au sénat sont remportées
par les démocrates
chaque camp aurait 50 sièges à la
chambre haute
il reviendrait alors à la future
vice-présidente kamala harris de
départager les votes en son sein en cas
d'égalité parfaite
joe biden pourrait ainsi s'appuyer sur
une majorité démocrate est déroulé son
programme sans entraves parlementaire
dans le cas où les républicains
remporterait au moins un des deux sièges
en géorgie le futur président devrait
composer avec un congrès divisé
donald trump n'a donc pas choisi la
géorgie par hasard pour son premier
meeting de poste présidentiel à peine
plus d'un mois après l'élection le
président républicain poursuit sa
campagne contestant l'élection de joe
biden et elle pourrait durer
donald trump a d'ores et déjà annoncé
son intention
de briguer un nouveau mandat en 2024
[Musique]